all right can you guys all hear me back
great so first of all thanks mark really
appreciate included in this group it's
been a fantastic day of science and I'm
really excited to tell you guys about
the work that we've been doing looking
at special functional specialization in
the mouse visual cortex so to me one of
the most amazing things about the
central nervous system is the ability to
take incredibly simple biophysical
inputs at the periphery and transform
them into the complex representations
and perceptions that we experience every
day and I think that the visual system
is a particularly good example of this
where light hits the photoreceptors in
the retina and this information has been
transformed into electrical signals that
are propagated from the retina to the
thalamus into the cortex in parallel
streams where it's segregated and
transformed into increasingly complex
representations such as for instance in
area MT which is well known for having a
very precise representation of the speed
and direction of stimuli or the inferior
temporal cortex which has an exquisite
representation of very fine colors are
more evasive and these transformations
have really captured the imaginations of
neuro scientists for many years and many
models exist about how these kinds of
transformations could take place through
the convergence of different anatomical
inputs and through physiological
transformations that might take place
due to a recruitment of inhibition and
excitation however to get at this level
of trying to really understand the
synaptic mechanisms that might underlie
these models what I and many others have
done is resorted to moving to the mouse
visual system to try to use it as a
model to understand visual processing I
mean while this has become a very
popular activity in the last five years
and maybe don't need to justify it quite
so much anymore I do want to take a
moment to step back and think about
whether the mouse is a reasonable system
to be studying visual processing it has
these tiny little beady eyes that are
the side of its head it doesn't really
have much of a binocular zone the it
doesn't have a phobia and so it's visual
acuity is very low and it's really just
not very much of a visual creature most
of its default sentences you need to be
olfaction it's not a sensation but I
think that but we need to really
understand whether we can may be trained
to use vision as a mode of as a mode of
sensation and whether we can then use
that behavioral tool to understand how
well they can see and what kind of
transformations do take place that a
visual processing in this system and so
my lab has been pushing hard on
different behavioral tools for the mouse
and I want to share one of the tasks
that we've developed most recently which
is a two alternative forced-choice
contrast detection task and in this task
the mouse's job is to use this treadmill
here to indicate whether it sees a
stimulus on the left or the right side
and so it slides it in the appropriate
direction so here's a mascarpone past
it's a tonal trial start diggin city
slides treadmill to the left to signal
us and nails on the right and I think as
the way that wave between the animals
past is by telling motion of the
treadmill to the motion of the
stimulants on the screen I'm you can't
it flash there on the correct home
that's another tool that means to really
try to engage the animal with that
visual stimulus that the combination of
the tethering of the treadmill um and
that stimulus on the screen we hope
really gets the animal to use it to use
the visual stimulus so you can see there
he got it most of the way up to where
the threshold is at the center of the
screen his job is to move a center and
then it didn't get quite all the way and
so we had to futz around with it to get
it there um so this is an animal that's
partly trained so it's still in the
training process once animals become
proficient at this task we can uncouple
the motion of the treadmill to motion
the stimulus and the animals will
continue to do this task where they
simply then respond to the left or the
right according to the position on the
screen and then we can change the
contrast of the stimulus to look at the
animals and so here is an example
session from a mouse so this is a single
session in which a
to the mountain about 200 you get any
trials of range between 200 and 400
miles a day and I would applaud any
hairs on the x-axis is the contrast
difference the right minus the left and
so for a contrast of one what that means
is that since the stimulus is always on
one side that the contrast is on the
right and since on the y-axis we're
putting the percent of right responses
it means the one hundred percent of the
time that the stimulus is on the right
he goes to the right and conversely if
the sim is a negative 1 that means it's
on the left and so zero pretend of the
time if it's on the left does he go to
the right and if we then present a range
of contrasts in between we're positive
ones or stimuli of low contrast on the
right and negative ones are stimuli of
low contrast on the left he has more
variable behavior and so sometimes he
gets it right and sometimes he gets it
wrong we can look at the reaction times
during this task so this is all a
cumulative distribution of all the
reaction times for this mouse we can
strain it that they can't respond until
about eight hundred and 50 milliseconds
after the stimulus appears and so but
even still the animals respond with
about ninety percent of the time within
two seconds they have up to about 25
seconds for each child before we end the
trial and start a new one so and
importantly here this green is for right
trials and blue is for left trials and
this but generally there we can train
them so that they have very little bias
and reaction time between the two styles
we can be more quantitative about this
reaction time by plotting the average
response time in terms of us difference
and so it's important here is that the
animals have faster response times for
easier for easier than you I slower ones
for harder stimuli and this is really
consistent with measurements and humans
and on human primates that as a task
it's more difficult reaction times get
slower maybe as a suggestion of changes
in the animals confidence finally we can
now we can take this data and use it to
measure the animals threshold so here
now I'm measuring the contrast
difference in absolute terms where one
is a hundred percent contrast on either
the left or the right and then
importantly the animal works at one
hundred percent contrast hundred percent
correct when for these easy
trials and that falls off with contrast
and we can measure a threshold of around
ten percent and so I want to point out
that while ten percent might not seem
like a very sensitive contrast threshold
this is actually fairly comparable to
what a contrast detection you might have
in your periphery where the density of
photoreceptors is actually more
comparable to the density of
photoreceptors in the past so this is a
summary of four different mice that
we've trained on this task and across
across multiple sessions where the error
bars are confidence intervals and I just
want to really point out that these mice
are extremely good at this task that for
all of them they always respond on the
right when this team is right and always
respond on the left when the stimulus is
on the left and that they're relatively
robust of failure and so we can probe
them at threshold level and will
continue to so one thing that we want to
know I think it's similar to what a Carl
told us about earlier today with these
simple tasks you want to understand
cortical transformations potentially is
it actually is the mouse actually using
the cortex to work and so in order to
get at this question we took advantage
of a line of mice that express courier
companies under there albumin positive
interneurons which are a population of
interneurons that specifically target
the cell bodies of neighboring principal
cells and so if we infect these neurons
with channelrhodopsin iris then we can
activate these cells on inner leave
trials and thereby determine whether if
we pair the activation with the
presentation of the stimulus whether it
affects their behavior on this task and
importantly we put the the channel
dobson specifically in their left visual
cortex which controls their responses to
the right visual field and so our
expectation is is that activation of
these neurons will specifically affect
their ability to text Emil on the right
side but not on the left and indeed
that's exactly what we see so again
plotting the contrast difference of
right- left on the x-axis and this is a
single mouse but over a number of
sessions what we see
under control conditions and these are
interleaved trials we have been really
nice symmetric a psychometric function
but if we then activate part of being
positive interneurons we specifically
have an impairment for stimuli on the
right visual hemifield and this is
really important because it suggests
that this isn't simply in effect on the
animals arousal that we're not startling
in with this activation there's these
kinds of cognitive changes this is
something that is really localized it is
not anything but have the receptive
fields for so I just wanted to show you
that data to suggest that mouse vision
is in fact sensitive if not highly
having high acuity they can perform
visual tasks and be very good
psychophysical subjects that they can
work at a hundred percent correct if
they're if they're well trained and the
mouse visual cortex does seem to be
important for however this is really
only half the hurdle of trying to
determine whether the mouse visual
system is it although for studying
visual processing the other half really
is a question about whether the visual
system has analogies to other more
complex systems for instance whether
there is parallel processing of
information in the visual cortex are
there hierarchical transformations that
are made and is there functional
specialization in these higher areas
that would be akin to if not analogous
to homologous to rather area MT or the
imperative world so I think that this
image here to me is one of the clearest
examples that there is parallel
processing in the mass visual cortex
this is an experiment from andres
Burkhalter that he did in which he made
three different x-trans injections into
the different retinotopic locations
within primary visual cortex and then
made a tangential section through the
brain in order to reveal the intro
greatly labelled projections of these
neurons to the higher visual areas and
so you can that this population of
neurons in v1 directly projects and our
projects to it integrates a
different higher visual areas
importantly the strongest projections
are two these are free area LMAO and
p.m. which are poorly named acronyms for
their locations in space but that it
does have projections to an array of
other areas and some that aren't even a
show um a second thing I'd like to point
out is that these but these projections
maintain retinotopic organization that
is that was set up in primary visual
cortex and that each of these higher
visual areas has a complete if not
equally balanced representation of the
entire visual field and suggests that
each of these areas probably has a
unique representation of the visual
world it might be important for
processing specialized features Andres
Burkhalter then went on to look at the
connectivity between each of these areas
and so here the thickness of the line is
representative of the strength of
connections between getting area and
while this looks like a hodgepodge of
connectivity where it's kind of an all
to all connection what he demonstrated
is that there actually is segregation of
these networks into functional streams
similar to what we see in the primates
wisdom but he identified a ventral
stream that these areas tend to project
two more perceptual or sensory related
targets such as the superficial superior
colliculus the big doula or the
n-terminal cortex whereas these more
dorsal motor related areas tended to
project to the motor cortex the
cingulate cortex or the deeper layers so
this really sets up a nice anatomical
structure that suggests that there is
parallel processing and functional
specialization within the network but we
still really need to know whether these
areas are all actually functionally
specialized and so in order to address
this question when I was in clay Reed's
lab we developed this preparation for
visualizing the entire Mouse visual
cortex and so we implant a five
millimeter
cranial window over the dorsal aspect of
the brain and this reveals primary
visual cortex as well as the array of
different higher visual areas that
protects too along with potentially
somewhat somatosensory cortex and other
cortical areas so we can then use these
windows to be able to identify
functionally the location of the
different higher visual area within the
window and so when you do this by
mapping it out with intrinsic signal
image and severe decrease using
fluorescence corresponding increases in
activity and so you can see this we move
a visual stimulus to different places
within the visual field so from medial
to lateral the representation these
areas move to different cortical
positions so v1 here moves from lateral
to medial cortex as you might expect
here from this mapping that andreas did
and similarly you can see mirror
reflections of LM and Al which are
separating from v1 as you move into
these more lateral position so we can
use the maps to target areas for
expression of genetically encoded
calcium indicators to look at the
activity of individual neurons within
these areas so this is an example
experiment of two-photon imaging of a
single neuron and its responses to a to
a range of different spatial and
temporal frequencies so here's an
example of the types of stimuli they
were using they're drifting gratings
moving a different is the width of one
of these bars as measured in cycles per
degree the temporal frequency is the
rate at which a cycle passes to a
particular position in space and is
measured in cycles per second and
importantly the ratio of temporal
frequency to spatial frequency is the
speed of the simular and so all of those
stimuli that lie along this axis are of
the same speed well those stimuli that
lie along this axis are of increasing
speed and so this particular neuron
responds with increases in fluorescence
from the genetically encoded indicator
gk gk 3 um too high temporal frequencies
and low spatial frequencies
and so and very selectively and so that
you don't see almost any responses to
prefer so if we look at the population
of neurons in v1 which as i showed you
individual neurons are very precisely
tuned the population is incredibly
diverse ly tuned so here dot represents
a single image neuron and its preferred
temporal and spatial frequency the
population covers this entire range of
presented spatial and temporal
frequencies and importantly we then
looked at the representation of these
neurons in cortical we saw a little
organization so here now each dot is
representation of a neurons position in
cortical space either in the coronal
plane where this is the pia and the
white matter or in the tangential plane
looking down on the service and each
this preferred speed of the neuron is a
color coded according to this map but we
saw a very little organization for speed
within this in either dimension and this
is really consistent with what other
people have seen in terms of the lack of
orientation training opportunity for
other features in the nostril corner
have a salt-and-pepper organization so
despite this lack of organization within
primary visual cortex we saw something
really different in the higher visual
areas namely that neurons and p.m. and
Al preferred very different sets of
Norns in p.m. preferred higher spatial
frequencies and lower temporal
frequencies while those in Al preferred
higher spatial higher temporal and lower
spatial frequency and importantly
they're even better defined along this
axis here of speed so neurons and Al
preferred fast speeds all neurons and
p.m. preferred slow speeds so to me this
sets up a really interesting
specialization within the mouse visual
cortex but neurons in v1 and LM which I
haven't shown you prefer a very diverse
array of speeds whereas those in Al and
p.m. are much more specialized where al
prefers fast speeds and p.m.
so to me this begs the question of how
this specialization could arise and I
see two main possibilities one
possibility is through local
computations within each of these areas
an alternative is that neurons in v1
could make specific projections that the
specialization could be inherited from
from v1 it's in order to test this
second hypothesis what we did was use
the same approach of making G camp
injections into primary visual cortex
but now we waited for the expression to
be trafficked out to the axons of those
neurons within the higher area and these
can then be seen as these as these
arborization these islands of
fluorescence on both in ex vivo
tangential sections as well as through
our cranial window if we cover up the
bright fluorescence in primary visual
cortex so then we can target these
islands for two photon imaging to look
at the responses of these axons to the
different types of stimuli and so this
is me an average movie of the responses
of axons with an area p.m. to the
different spatial and temporal frequency
state right and so what you can see is
that when a stimulus is presented you
see increases in fluorescence in these
axons which is due to the spiking of
cells that are millimeters away back in
v1 and importantly different stimuli
evoke activity in different populations
of axons so this is really great you now
use this approach ask the question about
whether v1 actually does send distinct
information by looking at the receptive
fields of the of these axons within the
higher areas so the way we analyze this
data was first by identifying all of the
axons that were active during that movie
by making a maximum F image and so if
you zoom in on a portion of this field
of view what you can see is that these
axons are actually comprised of strings
of hotspots that we think likely
correspond to synaptic boutons and so we
can then use an automated approach to
identify all the hot spots in the field
of view and measure their responses to
each of the different stimuli presented
and so these four boutons here map onto
these for bhutan
that have different colors up here and
so you can say that these boutons like
the neurons that we measured in primary
visual cortex that are sharply to
beijing temple and importantly boutons
that seem to come up from the same axon
share the same tuning properties which
you might expect that will that's
consistent with our expectation that
these responses are due to the
propagation of action potentials down
these axons rather than local processing
within the boutons so an importantly
that boutons on other dendrites can have
very different receptive fields
depending on so we can quantify this
data by making these arrays in which
each position corresponds to a
particular paired spatial or temporal
frequency and the area the circle
corresponds the amplitude of the
response and so then we can look at the
population of bhutan responses across a
given area and see that would its
average tuning is and so this is a set
of experiments from a single mouth so
single injection within primary visual
cortex and we're looking at is the
average response of three different
fields of you collected on three
different days one from p.m. LMK and al
and right away what you can see is that
the information is sent from this from a
homogeneous population heterogeneous
population in v1 sends distinct
information and this was true if we
looked at the population of thousands of
boutons on average that the boutons and
PM generally preferred slow speeds the
boutons and al generally preferred fast
speeds and those in LM preferred more
intermediates so this average difference
in response in bhutan tuning in targets
potentially arise from two different
mechanisms or two different anatomical
mechanisms really um one possibility is
that there's a difference in the
fraction of Boutin's given tuning within
each area and alternatively since these
are simply averages of each bhutan
within within the target there could
also be a contribution of the amplitude
of the partisan so that those ones that
are variegated speed have larger
responses and therefore swarm about the
other so it could either be at numbers
or an amplitude game and so in order to
distinguish between these possibilities
we got rid of the contribution of
amplitude and simply look at the
distribution so here we're looking on
the x-axis at the preferred speed of
those boutons and looking at the
cumulative distribution and this really
shows that the population of boo
Thompson al prefer faster speeds than
the population of boutons in PA moreover
if we look at the median speed with an
individual fields of view where
individual mice are connected with a
gray line we reliably saw higher median
speeds within al then in comparable
fields in p.m. so this really suggests
that in fact there is a difference in
the fraction of boutons of a given
importantly since we're just looking at
a population of Boutin's within this
area we can't distinguish between other
anatomical mechanisms such as whether
the population of neurons within v1 is
more likely to project to Al or PM or
whether once they get to Al or p.m. they
have larger arborization but nonetheless
this seems to explain some of the
specialization that might occur and
importantly that the median speed of the
boot talks with in a chariot match well
to the median speed of the neurons area
so this here the square represents the
median speed of the normal population
which matches well in Al and in PA so
this is a quick summary of what I've
told you about so far the population of
neurons in v1 is heterogeneous and
prefers a range of spatial and temporal
frequency whereas those in Al and PM are
more specialized and what we found by
the imaging axons within these target
areas is that the information that v1
sends these areas is in fact distinct
and there's a anatomical routing of this
information from v1 a higher visual
areas and moreover the function of these
projections seemed to match the function
of the higher areas and therefore could
provide some of the specialization that
we see of the receptive fields and the
target however I want to point out that
while the median speeds match here that
the distribution of
of preferred speeds of Boutin's and
axons are somewhat divergent so here in
light the light or the thin lines
represent the distribution of cell
bodies where the thick lines represent
the distribution of boutons within each
area and I want to point out that the
boutons within al for first slower
speeds than the cell bodies with an Al
and that the boutons within p.m. prefer
faster speeds than the cell bodies
within p.m. so this really suggests that
there might be some additional mechanism
of refinement that in addition to their
being these specific projections that
there could be local computations within
each of these areas further refine the
receptive fields in these parts so I
want to give you a little model of some
idea of what we think could be and one
possibility is that the refinement could
actually be happening at the synapse
from v1 to the target and so it's well
known that synapses can have very
divergent dynamics independent of the
pattern of action potentials that come
down that come down the axon so for
instance a high probability of release
synapses tend to have very depressing
synapses that resulted decrementing
membrane potential whereas low
probability release synapses tend to
have facilitating synapses that can lead
to the summation of membrane potential
and if we impose a threshold on these
membrane potentials I think this shows
is that you could then imagine having
very different dynamics of postsynaptic
spiking responses in response to
different height facilitating versus
depressing synapses we're depressing
synapses might act as a low-pass filter
and thereby cut off cut off high
temporal frequencies whereas
facilitating synapses might act is a
high-pass filter I'm thereby permitting
high temporal frequencies and so one
hypothesis is that Al and PM might be
distinguished by having different
properties of synaptic transmission at
the out at the input stage from v1 to
that higher visual areas but al might
have more facilitating synapses where's
PA
so in order to get at this question we
decided to take an in vitro approach I
actually I'm recording from neurons
within the higher visual areas while
stimulating their inputs um however this
is a difficult problem because if you
stick a stimulation electrode out in
these higher visual areas you're going
to activate a whole range of of inputs
coming from all sources and we really
specifically want to look at the inputs
coming from v1 and so this really is a
question that requires optogenetics in
order to study it and so we would make a
viral injections of channelrhodopsin and
to be one and allow the virus to traffic
out to the higher visual areas and then
we can make wholesale recordings from
these puffballs while stimulating those
axons did look at the properties of
synaptic transmission however I want to
point out that um it's really important
if we want to look at the dynamics of
synapses across these across distances
and using optogenetic tools that we
really validate whether channelrhodopsin
in particular and optogenetic tools in
general can be used to probe the
dynamics of these projections for
instance it's known that general Dobson
undergoes significant amounts of
inactivation and so this could
potentially make it unsuitable however
people have shown that whole cell
recordings and Saul attached recordings
from neurons expressing channelrhodopsin
can that those neurons can be driven to
fire at frequencies of 20 to 30 Hertz
reliably um even for trains of 10 action
potentials however axons might be a
totally different story they are severed
from their cell bodies and so and
generally especially these ones are
millimeters away from the from the
source of the opposite in generation
therefore might have lower densities of
the optogenetic proteins have unjust
have smaller surface areas so this is
something we really wanted to test and
see if we actually are able to reliably
stimulate these cortical projections
however this in itself is a problem
because there's really not a very good
way to directly record from these axons
as i said the cell bodies are cut off
and so we can't record from them while
I'm stimulating
for their axon and recording from
individual axons in a slice well
possible is incredibly and so instead we
decided to take an indirect approach of
recording extracellular leaf from these
acts on populations and so here is a
slight and image from a slice that we've
recorded from a fluorescent image of
this axon cloud innervating a higher
visual area an extracellular recording
electrode in layer 23 and we when we
shine blue light on these axons we see
this this compound potential and I just
want to take a moment to talk about all
the different types of conductances that
are contained the first of all there's
the conductance of channelrhodopsin
itself which then activate through
depolarization optic axons activates
sodium channels to drive action
potentials and and activation of
potassium channels which then activates
voltage-gated calcium channels drives
neurotransmitter release activation of
postsynaptic EMPA NMDA i metabotropic
glutamate receptors and which then
drives postsynaptic action potentials as
well as a variety of die synaptics
interactions and recruitment of
additional excitation and inhibition so
this is got a lot of stuff going on but
really what we want to do is be able to
isolate this presynaptic action
potential that fiber folly so in order
to do this our first approach was to
apply that would apply AMPA and NMDA
receptor antagonists in these glutamate
receptor blockers and that gets rid of
responses of these in Tampa NMDA
receptors as well as the postsynaptic
action potentials and the variety of die
synaptic conductances that might be a
vote as well and so you can visualize
this field postsynaptic potential which
is composed of all these monosynaptic
and die synaptic potentials as well as
probably a lot of voltage-gated
conductances um and and so whereas the
remainder of this is going to be mostly
pre synaptic conductances as well as
maybe some activation and metabotropic
glutamate receptors so then to further
isolate
presynaptic action potential we're now
going to apply cadmium to block to block
calcium channels and so this is
important because we don't want the
calcium channel conductance to to
contaminate our sodium channel reserve
action potential response but it also
serves to block synaptic transmission
thereby blocking metabotropic glutamate
receptors as well and then now we can
finally apply to trota toxin to block
voltage-gated sodium channels which has
the added effect of blocking action
potentials as well as a lot of the
voltage-gated potassium conductance and
leaving us with here with this red trace
which likely corresponds to the option
potential itself and the subtraction of
these will give us our fiber volley and
so we contend that this fiber volley is
going to be a good measure of the
average ACT activation of these
presynaptic axons from v1 for a couple
of reasons one of which is if we as we
increase the light power two of the LED
we see an increment both the amplitude
of the ops and potential as well as the
amplitude of the hyperbola itself and so
this is giving us now an average
response at the population of axons that
were activating coming into this area I
would actually even argue that this is a
while indirect maybe a better measure
than recording from individual axons
because it gives us an unbiased approach
to look at the entire population of
axons that's recruited and moreover it's
going to be the identical identical
configuration to what we'll be looking
at ultimately if when we're doing
wholesale recordings from detox from
these neurons and stimulating these
axons okay so what happens now if we
stimulate these axons at a high
frequency so this is here I'm overlaying
fiber volume sponsors this is channel or
doc at 20 Hertz where the black trace is
the response to the first pulse an
increasing trait increasing lighting its
course oscillator holes and what you can
see immediately is that that fiber
volley becomes much smaller and slower
and this is true we look across a range
of different temporal frequencies that
even the slowest 10 Hertz the axons
able follow stimulation with
channelrhodopsin importantly that not
only did we see changes in the
reliability but we also saw changes in
the fidelity that the timing of the
fiber volleys became later and later
during the Train increasing you recycle
and importantly this is not simply an
intrinsic property of these axons if
we've now placed an extracellular
stimulating electrode in the tissue and
looked at the recruitment of fiber
volleys we saw that we could very well
stimulate these at stimulate axons in
the cortex they had very high
reliability and stable latency and so I
just really want to point out here that
um this really suggests that general
Dobson is totally unsuitable for
stimulation it we agree even my guess is
at frequencies well below 10 Hertz but
instead we need to look to other tools
for this approach and in order to start
thinking about what tools we might want
to use we wanted to try to really
understand you know what is what's
causing this this effect and our
intuition is that the highlight powers
that we need to use to action potentials
in these axons I'm really exacerbate the
inactivation of these channels and so
here now we're looking at the opsin
potential that was recorded so this is
now in the presence of all of our
antagonists and again where we've
overlaid at 20 Hertz these these
potentials and black is the first pulse
and gray as the last pulse that we see
this market use dependent decrease in
the amplitude of the option potential
that we think is probably due to channel
channel inactivation don't think this is
due to changes in driving force because
if we do do wholesale recordings from
neurons we strong an activation of these
currents as well so this leads us to
think that we really need to use new
tools that maybe undergo lesson
activation and that kitten that brought
us to to newer options I'm a chief and
Cronin's a chief is developed in Roger
Chen's lab and Chronos here by avoiding
and both of these options that is their
whole cell recording is now
wholesale currents normalized that Oh
chief is actually has undergoes very
little inactivation up to 100 Hertz you
start to see some fall off and Curtis is
also quite good and it's much better
than Chong rhodopsin although starts
falling off maybe at 40 Hertz so now we
wanted to test whether these newer
options might be better tools for
activating these axons so we went back
to stimulating the axioms themselves and
recording the fiber volleys and so here
it is to example experiments one from a
chief and one from Cronus already that
these fiber volleys are much more
reliable and stable throughout the tree
summary of data again for a chief and
Chronos that O'Keefe is remarkably
stable up to 60 Hertz search fall off at
100 Hertz Chronos is very stable up to
20 Hertz falls off a little bit at 40
and a little bit more importantly they
also show relatively stable Layton sees
not as stable as the electrical
microstimulation that I showed it but
that again it's fairly good and you
really buy I can see very little change
the time now that we found it two of you
found a couple of tools that we can use
to reliably axons in vitro over the
previous analysis so now returning back
to our preparation where we have these
axonal arborization that are innervate
al and p.m. we can now make recordings
from these areas to look the properties
so just as a first pass I want to show
you some data actually looking at the
field potentials themselves and so this
is a field potential recorded in p.m.
and this is again I've been showing
mostly the ops and potentials of the
fiber volleys now we're going back to
this initial condition where we just
have the control minus the AMPA and NMDA
receptor blockers and importantly we're
really just going to isolate this rising
phase because I
the part that we really trust as being
probably the monosynaptic and so you can
see is that at lower frequencies there's
actually very little dynamic of the
input from v1 to p.m. but then as you
increase frequencies you actually see
something that's really commonly
observed so is it facilitation followed
by depression and indeed that's what we
saw across the population in p.m. which
was actually distinct from al so where
is it lower temporal frequencies both of
them both inputs to a 0 and p.m. were
relatively stable should very little
plasticity as you increase frequencies
they begin to diverge or as inputs to
where inputs to a I'll become more
facilitating and inputs to PM more
depression and we don't think this is
simply due to activation over the axon
terminals themselves that were causing
looks because if we move our laser down
to layer 5 and activate there instead we
see their response so this is a this was
consistent with our model this idea that
maybe the inputs from v1 so the higher
visual areas might be specialized where
those two al might be more facilitating
them maybe not as dramatically as I as I
schematized we're currently doing
wholesale recordings trying to replicate
this to really look to see whether it is
those monosynaptic epscs that are that
are distinctly modulated in but we're
also continuing to look for other
mechanisms that might support the
specialization within these downstream
areas so for instance where excitation
might mediate this different film
property you can imagine that a
complementary inhibitory circuit could
further refine these inputs so for
instance if you added a facilitating
inhibition to a depressing excitation
you might further just emphasize your
low pass filter or is a depressing x8
inhibition plus a facilitating
excitation would further emphasize your
high pass filter and so we know that
there are different types some types of
inhibitory neurons
that act exactly in this way but for
instance parvalbumin expressing
inhibitory neurons receive strongly
depressing synapses and therefore
impinge on pyramidal cells with
depressing inhibition whereas
somatostatin positive interneurons
Center received facilitating and
therefore impinge on their target
profiles with facilitating image and so
these so one hypothesis is that for
instance there might be different
densities of parvalbumin positive and
somatostatin positive neurons across
different cortical areas that might
match with this model to further refine
these different temporal frequent and so
the way that we approached this was by
using three different lines that connect
mice we use a lot we used somatostatin
irish creed that we crossed a flexed ed
tomato problem and i agree that we
crossed a flexed ed tomato as well and
then these jin gfp mice which is a
transgenic line that expresses gfp
specifically it's not a statin cells
that are likely maar dena t cells and
are the ones that really receive
strongly facilitating x8 and then what
we did is made viral injections into
primary visual cortex to express gfp in
these two lions or gido in this line
people to identify the axon to the
higher visual areas axons interv aiding
the higher visual areas so essentially
define our regions of interests of the
retina topically matched regions within
the higher visual areas so this is an
example section so we made 70 70 microns
sections through the brain facts and so
in magenta here are the is the TD tomato
expression of the somatostatin
expressing interneurons and some creed
line and you see the expected bright
fluorescence in layer 1 and a lot of
these neurons and their axons up to that
layer and again we see the v1 axons
innervating the higher visual area and
so we write our region of interest on
and to maintain
representation importantly this is an
example of a Debbie stain from the slice
that allows us to identify the laminar
location of these neurons and so then we
just went through and counted or
undergraduate students went through and
counted all of these inhibitory neurons
and identified their location along the
coronal axis of these slices and
repeated the same thing for gin cells as
well as the PB Cree cells and so I want
to point out two things one that um the
gin cells generally tended to be in the
more superficial layers and so maybe
correspond more to the somatostatin
cells and the superficial layers of
these mice and secondly that the inputs
from v1 to the higher visual areas tend
to arbor eyes mostly in layers to 3
through 5 and so we really restricted
our analysis to those layers input that
where the key is going to be populated
so these are the results of a lot of
cell counting so in the pv Cree line
four so for each of these lines that we
measured is the relative change in
density in Al versus p.m. and so here we
saw in twenty percent increase in the
number of p v+ inter neurons in al
compared to p.m. and a fifteen percent
decrease in the number of janelle's in
Al compared to p.m. interestingly if we
look at the the some curry line that it
came out around equal but if we then
divided these neurons up and according
to being layer 2 3 vs layer 5 now these
segregated kind of interestingly where
the somme cree cells and layer 23 look a
little bit more like the gin cells as i
pointed out kind of anatomically whereas
the somme cree cells and layer 5 are
actually more strongly represented in Al
and p.m. so this really suggest that
there may be some kind of difference in
the recruitment of inhibitions these two
different areas that could support the
specialization in the temporal frequency
that we observe
and we're currently doing wholesale
recordings to look at this as well to
look at the recruitment different vision
strength of inputs as well on to each of
these different satellites are good but
either way I was actually really
surprised by the result that there are
these different densities of inhibitory
neurons across areas and really suggest
that while there might be canonical
micro circuits within cortex that the
balance of those circuits really be
specialized across different areas on
it's probably going to be interesting
for understanding how different
modalities are processed as well and so
in summary I'd like to argue that in
addition to having shown you that there
are specific projection from v1 to the
higher visual areas but they're also
seem to be local computations within a
theory that there are potentially
differences in inputs from v1m the v1
synapses to their targets as well as the
recruitment of local inhibitory circuits
and that these may be specialized to
refine the tuning in the spectrum of the
neurons within these areas and so I just
like to end by thanking a lot of people
first Jeff Sims was an undergraduate who
got all of the behavior working that I
showed you it started um mark and Herman
and Vincent Bonin and clay read in the
reed lab I did all of the imaging
experiments with them John Mansell and
Mark hi stead were instrumental in
getting a lot of those behavioral
experiments going as well Charlie Haas
did all of the slice electrophysiology
and with Amy crystal did the anatomy and
Greg Horowitz provided us with some
viruses and I what to think one being
and all of you